J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So we're
studying reaction
mechanisms this semester, but
we'd taken a little diversion to
look at reaction order--
how the dependence of rate on
concentration gives
information about mechanism.
So this is the kinetic analog of
the law of mass action, the
exponents we talked about on
concentration last semester.
And we saw last time that we
would have rate laws, the
d(Product)/dt is some function
of concentration raised to
some power.
And we looked last time at zero
order and first order and
second order.
Now we're going to look at some
complex reactions and how
they can get weird orders like
fractional orders or even
inverse orders.
So a fractional order:
Suppose the rate is proportional
to some rate
constant times the concentration
of A times the
concentration of B to the 1/4
power.
How can that be?
How can you have 1/4 of a
molecule
participate in a reaction?
Well, this all depends on when a
reactive species in
equilibrium with other species,
what is
the dominant species?
Because when you add more
material to a solution, what
you increase is the dominant
species by how much you add.
If you double it you have twice
as much of
the dominant species.
If you triple it you have three
times as much of the
dominant species.
But suppose what's reacting is
not the dominant species, but
is related to the dominant
species by
some equilibrium constant.
So, for example, suppose the
dominant species were a
tetramer, four units.
But the reactive species were a
monomer, a single B unit.
So you have the equilibrium
between B4 and 4B.
Now if B4 is dominant and B is
reactive, then if you double
the concentration--
or actually let's say you
increase the concentration by
a factor of 2, 4, 6, 8--
you increase the concentration
by a factor of 8.
How much do you increase the
concentration of B4?
It's practically all the stuff,
it's the dominant
species, so you increase it by a
factor of 8.
By how much do you increase the
concentration of the
monomer, B, that's in
equilibrium with it?
So if the dominant species is
proportional to how much you
add, that's how much you think
you have. But the minor
species tags along following the
law of mass action.
So we actually, last semester,
talked about a tetramer--
that methyllithium gives this
distorted cubic tetramer.
Remember it has four ether
molecules associated with it
if possible.
But if you put in a lot more
ether then it rips the
tetramer apart, because all the
oxygens want to be sharing
their electrons with lithium.
So excess ether rips it apart,
first to give a dimer with two
more methyl ethers per dimer
unit.
And ultimately to a monomer with
another methyl ether per
monomer unit.
So each monomer now has three
dimethyl ethers.
So if you have plenty of
dimethyl ethers, then the
equilibrium shifts to the right,
and most of the stuff
is monomer.
And if you increase the material
you put in by a
factor of 8, you'll increase the
monomer by a factor of 8.
But that's not what happened
when you don't have the excess
ether available.
Then the equilibrium lies to the
right, and when you ladle
8 times as much material in--
you don't ladle it because
it's very reactive with air and
water.
But if you increase the
concentration by a factor of
4, this is what you increase by
a factor of 4.
And how do you increase that?
Well, you have this equilibrium
constant where the
monomer is to the fourth power,
so the monomer to the
fourth is proportional to the
tetramer.
Or you could write the same
thing, the monomer is
proportional to the tetramer to
the one fourth power.
2, 4, 8--
16 was what I was supposed to
say, right?
So if I increase the tetramer by
a factor of 16, I increase
the monomer by 16 to the one
fourth power
by: a factor of 2.
So it would only double the
rate.
So reaction of monomer in a
hydrocarbon solvent turns out
to be 1/4 order in how much
reagent you add.
But the reaction order proves
then that the monomer is
reactive, but the tetramer is
dominant in the hydrocarbon.
But if you have excess ether,
then the reaction shifts to
the left, and if you add 16
times as much stuff you
increase the concentration of
the monomer
by a factor of 16.
Then it's first order in how
much stuff you added, and the
reaction becomes first order.
So that's one example of a weird
kinetic rate law, a
weird dependence on
concentration, fractional.
Suppose you had a 1/6 order
reaction?
What would you infer?
Elisa?
STUDENT: That it's a hexamer.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That the dominant species is a
hexamer, but the reactive
species is a monomer.
Good.
Now here are two enantiomers, an
R and an S configuration of
this funny molecule that's a
little bit
related to amino acids.
Now it has what are called
alpha-hydrogens--
those are hydrogens attached to
a carbon adjacent to a
carbonyl group.
So it turns out that a base can
pull off that hydrogen,
leaving an anion on that carbon,
which then is
stabilized by pi-star of the
carbonyl.
So it's easy to pull off that H
and put it back on again.
So that means that if you put
base in with these two
molecules they'll interconvert
easily.
Now that would lead to
racemization.
If you started with all one
hand, you'd have a reaction
going one way which has a
certain rate constant times
the base, and a reaction going
the other way which is the
same rate constant, because
they're mirror images, times
the concentration of base.
Now the rate, how much goes from
one side to the other, is
the rate constant times the
concentration.
So if you have a higher
concentration of one than of
the other, its rate will be
faster.
So as it says here that since
they're identical rate
constants for the two
enantiomers that guarantees a
faster rate for the major
concentration, the major
enantiomer going to the minor
enantiomer, until they
equilibrate, they come to 50/50,
and then the
rates will be equal.
So that's a guaranteed mechanism
for racemization.
You have an alpha-hydrogen at
the chiral center, or the
stereogenic center.
You put base in, pull it off,
put it on, and you've lost all
the effort you've put in to make
the thing a single
enantiomer in the beginning.
Incidentally, how do you make
something a single enantiomer?
When you generate something,
typically you make both right
and left equally with equal
probability.
But what you have to do,
remember as we talked about
last semester, Pasteur, one of
Pasteur's methods, is to react
it with something pre-existing
that's only one enantiomer in
some reversible reaction.
So you can make the pair of
enantiomers into
diastereomers, separate them
perhaps by crystallization,
then take them back to what you
want.
That's how you get one to begin
with.
It depends on having something
pre-existing
that's a single hand.
Now these two molecules turn out
to crystallize, and they
crystallize in crystals that are
composed all of one
enantiomer or all of the other.
So if you let such a mixture
crystallize, it would give 50%
of one crystal, 50% of the other
crystal--
it would be racemic.
Except if you grind it.
So there was this very
interesting paper two years
ago by a group in the
Netherlands--
Noorduin was the lead author--
about grinding a suspension of
these crystals.
That is there is these right and
left handed crystals of
that compound.
When they're in solution they
can interconvert, because
there's base in there.
So the molecule comes off the
crystal, goes into solution,
racemizes, and then goes back on
one crystal or the other.
So the experiments lasted some
time, you see, up to 50 or 60
or 70 days.
And they looked in the solid
phase of the crystals at what
the enantiomer excess was-- how
much more of one crystal
there was than the other.
And they started with a little
bit of excess of either the S,
those are the blue points, or
they R,
those are the red points.
And I notice we have these front
lights on.
I better turn those off to get
better
definition on the slides.
So we have red or blue.
It could be a very tiny excess,
like 0.04%.
Now what would you expect from
what I've been telling you if
you had base in the solution and
you start grinding to
encourage the crystals to
dissolve more rapidly?
What would you expect to happen
in time?
Suppose you started with the one
that's 17% excess of S?
What would happen in time?
Come on, be naive.
Megan, what do you think would
happen?
STUDENT: Less enantiomeric
excess?
PROFESSOR: Can't hear very well.
STUDENT: Less enantiomeric
excess?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it would go to
zero in enantiomer excess,
it would go to 50/50.
So you'd expect a curve that
would look like this.
It would go along, depending on
how fast it is, it would
become zero.
This is what actually happened.
So it DE-racemized.
It became a single enantiomer.
Whatever was in excess at the
beginning, all the crystals
became that.
So this is very different from
what we were talking about
before where the rate law
guarantees that whatever's in
excess will go more rapidly to
the minor than the minor to
the major, and it's guaranteed
to come out 50/50.
This one goes exactly the
opposite.
So this was a great puzzle, what
caused this to happen.
It could be that there's faster
conversion
of the minor crystals.
So that if you have, say, more
R than S, it's faster to go
from S to R than from R to
S. What would that say
about the rate law?
If the less concentration you
have, the fewer crystals, the
faster it goes.
It's an inverse rate law.
That certainly sounds weird.
But there's another interesting
thing.
The lines have a curious shape.
Do you see what's funny about as
a reaction goes along
having this kind of shape or
this kind of shape?
Remember, we looked last time at
a first-order reaction or a
second-order reaction, what it
looked like.
You started with a given
starting material and what
happened in time?
It went to product.
It went to zero concentration.
But how do it go?
It went like this, because the
more of it there was the
faster it was going--
half-life, half-life, half-life.
This seems to be backwards.
And you see it both in the fact
that it goes all to one,
to the major one, and in the
fact that you
have these funny curves.
Now the explanation is that when
you're grinding you make
tiny, tiny pieces that are
guaranteed to dissolve.
So grinding accelerates
dissolution by making very
tiny crystals below the critical
size that we talked
about last semester.
So they'll dissolve, they won't
grow.
Except they can be rescued from
dissolution by combining
with another crystal of the same
kind.
So the crystal could grow not by
adding one molecule at a
time, but by two small crystals
coming together.
Now that's going to be second
order in how many of these
little pieces there are.
If two things are coming
together, two A's are coming
together, that second order in
A. So the more stuff there is
the faster it avoids
dissolution.
So really it's a second-order
process of avoiding
dissolution.
But that means that if you're
looking at the dissolution,
which allows stuff to go from
one to the other, that's
faster if you have less stuff
because you don't save it.
So the majority solid dissolves
more slowly than the
minority solid does, because it
could be saved by a second-
order process.
But the key to understanding
this really weird phenomenon
was the kinetics, to see that
the lines
had these funny shapes.
That's what clued people in to
the idea that it was this
coalescence of little shards of
crystals that made the
thing to do this.
And this could be of interest.
The people who do this, the
reason they're motivated to do
it other than they just think
it's cool, is people have always
wondered how it is that
in the biosphere things had a
single hand, that all amino
acids are L-amino acids and all
sugars are D-sugars, or
most sugars at least. How did
things get resolved in the
first place when there wasn't
anything preresolved to do
this separation we talked about?
But this can start at 50/50.
If you have a lot of particles,
it's never exactly 50/50--
there'll be a little bit more of
one than the other.
So one of them will be saved
from dissolution a little more
than the other, an ultimately
that one will build up
autocatalytically--
the more it goes, the faster it
goes.
So that seems to be the
explanation of this phenomenon
that could, indeed, have
something to do with the
origin of single handedness in
the biosphere.
But the key to understanding it
was the
kinetics, the rate law.
So we've seen the guidance that
rate laws can provide for
understanding reaction
mechanisms--
zeroth order, that's when the
catalyst is saturated.
First order is the normal
business.
Second order when two things
have to get together.
Fractional order when things
have to come apart.
And negative order, in this
case, although you could argue
that it's actually second order,
but it appears to be
negative order, that the minor
stuff goes more rapidly.
So now back to what we were
talking about, the reaction
we're talking about, which is
bond dissociation to generate
free radicals.
The reason we're talking about
that is try to figure out how
you can predict rate constants
from things we already know.
So we're studying free-radical
substitutions for this purpose
because a) they're simple.
There's minimal influence from
the solvent, so you can just
look at the molecules that are
doing the reaction and try to
understand the rates.
They also turn out to be very
important, these
free-radical reactions.
They're very important in
atmospheric chemistry.
So there's a lot of work done on
them in,
say, Boulder, Colorado, where
the Atmospheric Administration
and the Joint Institute for
Laboratory Astrophysics are very
interested in
these kinds of things.
They're important in combustion,
you make free radicals.
Also in oxidation reactions that
we'll
talk about more later.
In terms of strictly organic
chemistry, they provide great
examples of selectivity.
And that's a pervasive theme, as
I say here, in synthesis
and in biochemistry.
Almost always with any kind of
complicated molecule, the
problem is not what can react--
there are always lots of
different ways of reacting.
The question is how you can be
selective and do one thing
rather than another.
That's often the problem in
organic synthesis--
is being selective.
And the free-radical reactions
are a very simple example of
showing something about
selectivity, as we'll see
later in the lecture.
So last time we were looking at
this table of experimental
bond dissociation energies, bond
enthalpies as they're called.
There are a zillion of them and
they're known very well.
But what we would like to
understand is why.
Why do they have these values?
So you don't have to memorize
the whole table.
That is, do you just have to
suck it up and memorize this,
or can you understand this kind
of lore--
what the rate constant should
be, what the energy should be
for the strength of these bonds
that
you're trying to break?
Well, it's very difficult to
predict exactly what these
energies should be.
But often you can predict
relative energies.
If you'd know one, you can
predict another one.
so most often in exams,
questions I'd ask on exams,
It's not a question of knowing
the precise rate, but if you
knew the rate for this, what
would the rate for this be?
And you notice that it has to do
with selectivity, when you
have two processes that are
analogous to one another that
can go on, how much better
should one be than the other?
That's much easier to get the
relative values than to get
the absolute values.
We started last time looking at
this, in the case of the
bonds to methyl from the various
halogens.
Remember, that it has to do with
overlap?
That as you make the halogens
bigger the
overlap isn't so good.
And also that has to do with
energy
match between the orbitals--
we talked about this last
lecture.
We also talked about other cases
where the
radicals were unusual.
That, remember, had to do with
starting material, how strong
the bond is.
But then others had to do with
how stable the radicals were.
Like the hybridization of the
C-H and the resonance--
the SOMO mixing with pi and
pi*, we talked about that
last time--
has to do with the radical,
whereas the hybridization that
explains the strong ones has to
do with the starting
material, how strong the C-H
bonds are.
So we've done that.
Now let's look at a more subtle
example, which is as we
go from one alkyl radical to
another, breaking hydrogens
off from carbon, but from just
different alkanes.
And the first thing we notice
there is that
they're not very different.
You can explain this by saying
that the carbon-carbon bond is
more sensitive to hybridization,
its energy,
than the carbon-hydrogen bond
is.
Now when you go from a
tetrahedral carbon, the
starting material, you pull off
an H and get a radical,
which is trigonal.
You go from sp3 to sp2 bonds.
And the sp2 bonds, as we saw
last semester, overlap better
and give stronger bonds.
That's fine.
That'll be true, they'll be
stronger if they're bonded to
hydrogen; they'll be stronger if
they're bonded to carbon.
But it turns out that
carbon-carbon bonds are more
sensitive to the hybridization
than carbon-H is.
So if when you're pulling the
hydrogen off from your
tetrahedral carbon there are
other carbons attached to that
carbon, then in the process of
going to the radical you'll
get more extra stability than
you would have if there had
been hydrogens there, because
the carbons profit from the
change in hybridization more
than the
hydrogens would have done.
So that's what we see here.
Methyl, which has three
hydrogens is
hard to form the radical--
104.9.
But it gets easier and easier
and easier as you go to more
and more carbon-carbon bonds
rather than hydrogen-carbon
bonds on the radical you're
making.
So that's one explanation: that
the
carbon-carbon is more sensitive.
And that's to say that that's
why the
radical is more stable.
It has to do with the stability
of the radical.
The other possibility is
analogous to what we saw over
here in the allyl and benzyl
cases.
It was where the SOMO mixes with
pi and pi* on
the adjacent carbon.
So we're going to pull a
hydrogen off here, make a
radical, a p-orbital here.
If we had a pi system here
that could overlap with that
we mix it with pi, mix with
pi*, and get
stabilization.
We looked at that last time.
Now, of course, if you have a
hydrogen here attached to the
carbon from which the hydrogen
is being lost, it's
orthogonal; it can't overlap
with the p-orbital here.
But if you have a carbon here
with a hydrogen on it, then
that s and s* bond of C-H can
overlap with the p-orbital.
So you can get the same kind of
mixing that you get with pi
and pi*, except it's s and
s*.
So they're much further away in
energy-- the energy match
is much poorer with this
p-orbital.
So you don't expect it to be a
very big phenomenon, and the
changes here, indeed, are not
nearly as big as they were for
benzyl and allyl.
But those are the explanations
that are standard for
explaining why more substituted
radicals are more stable.
That's what people say, so it's
easier to break the bond.
That is, they say that it has to
do with
this radical stability.
Notice we're assuming that the
bond dissociation energy
difference, as you go across
from methyl to ethyl to
isopropyl to t-butyl is due to
differences in radical
stabilities, not the differences
in the starting
material energy.
Remember, it could be either.
The standard explanations are in
terms of the radical.
And what I'm going to show you
now is that
that's not so obvious.
Even though I think it would be
interesting for you to look
in these various textbooks that
you have at this subject
about free-radical
halogenation--
every one of them will have a
chapter about that.
And see what they say about what
the explanation is.
Some of them won't give any
explanation at all, they'll
just say more substituted
radicals are more stable.
But those which give an
explanation
will give one of these.
But I want to show you that it's
not so obvious that
that's true.
If it were true, we can test it
by checking more examples.
Instead of looking only at
hydrogen breaking away to give
those different radicals, we
could break other things away.
There's not enough data for
fluorine, but chlorine,
bromine, iodine, methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl, t-butyl all
can be broken away from these
radicals, and they all should
show the same phenomenon, if it
has to do with the stability
of the radicals rather than the
starting material.
So that's what we're going to do
is expand the scope of what
we're looking at using that
table.
So here is R along here and X.
We're going to break X away
from R and leave the R radical.
Now what connects B?
X can be hydrogen, that's this.
Those are the data we just
looked at, and we explained it
in terms of different stability
of the radicals that
are being left behind when you
pull the hydrogen away.
And here are all the different
alkyls--
methyl, ethyl, isopropyl,
t-butyl.
Breaking chlorine away is the
green one,
about like the alkyls.
Breaking bromine away is the red
one, and iodine.
Now what this shows is that
bonds to iodine are much
weaker than bonds to hydrogen.
Iodine forms weaker bonds than
bromine, than
chlorine, than hydrogen.
Fine.
So hydrogen is stronger than
R-C. R-C is about the same as
R-Cl, but R-Cl is stronger than
R-Br, and R-I is the
weakest, whatever the radical
you're breaking away.
Now there are some obvious
differences here that the
phenyl, when phenyl is the group
that's being broken away
in the left column here, it's
unusually hard to break away.
And we saw why that was last
time.
They have good overlap because
you have sp2 C-X bonds that
have to be broken.
They are the strongest--
whatever X you're breaking away
that's
the strongest bond.
And on the far right we see that
if you have allyl and
benzyl you get those resonant
stabilized radicals.
And no matter what X you're
breaking away that's the best.
What we want to do is now focus
on these ones in the
middle and see if we can
understand these ones where
the various methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl and t-butyl are the
radicals being left behind, and
see whether the data as a
whole echoes what we saw in
hydrogen, that more
substituted radicals are more
stable.
So all these should be the same.
That is, it's going to be
different depending on which
atom we're pulling away, but the
relative stability of the
radicals as we go across a given
color should be the
same, if that's the explanation.
So here's when we're breaking H
off.
And now I've blown up the scale
so
we can see the variation.
So we're going to compare it.
These are relative bond
dissociation energies, taking
zero to be methyl.
So we see that it's 4
kilocalories easier to break
hydrogen away from ethyl.
Another 2 and a fraction to get
isopropyl.
And another couple to get
t-butyl.
So people do say, your books
I'll guarantee you will say,
that those radicals as they're
more
substituted are more stable.
But if it's true, it should be
the same whenever we're
breaking away from the radicals.
So what they tend to say, for
example, the Jones and
Flemming book that I mentioned,
on page 479, sp2
s bonds to carbon are
preferentially stabilized the
more substituted radicals.
The C-C overlap is more
sensitive to hybridization
than C-H. That's what I just
told you.
And they also say on page
478-479, there's probably a
bit of stabilization from SOMO
overlap with s and
s*.
That's what I said last time.
Now let's see.
So if this trend is due to
radical stabilization by these
two phenomena, then whatever X
we break off we should show
the same trend.
So here's when
we break t-butyl,
when we break t-butyl away from
the various radicals.
That is, break the bond between
t-butyl and methyl,
between t-butyl and ethyl,
between t-butyl and isopropyl,
or between two t-butyls.
And indeed it looks pretty much
the same.
Within the error probably, these
are the same trend.
So that looks good.
But look at the others.
If you break these others off
they don't show--
they show it's always going
down, but not nearly as
dramatically.
So it can't be just the
difference in stability of
methyl, ethyl, isopropyl and
t-butyl.
There has to be something in the
starting material that's
contributing to this.
It makes a difference what it is
you're breaking away.
Now, t-butyl is a very special
compound
because it's so crowded.
So if you put two t-butyls
together, it's very crowded.
And that could make the starting
material unstable and
relatively easy to break the
bond.
But we can calculate how much
unstability there is due to
that by using molecular
mechanics, as we mentioned at
the end last semester.
So we can calculate strain
energy in the starting
material using molecular
mechanics.
This is the amount of strain
energy you count in two
t-butyls (t-butyl-t-butyl),
t-butyl, in t-butyl with
isopropyl, in t-butyl with
ethyl, and in
t-butyl with methyl.
That's how much strain energy
there is in
the starting material.
Let's just look at the one there
to see
where it comes from.
So here are two t-butyls bonded
to one another with
idealized bond lengths and
angles.
And we calculate by molecular
mechanics, if we have normal
C-C and C-H bond distances,
normal angles at carbons, how
much strain will there be due to
things
running into one another.
Because you'll notice if you
make a space-filling model of
that you can see down the middle
its crunch region.
Now how big is that?
The van der Waals energy
calculated for this from these
things running together is 26.9
kilocalories per mole--
pretty high.
Now, of course, the molecule
doesn't have that shape.
It adjusts, as we mentioned last
semester, to
minimize the energy.
So what it does is adjust to
that position.
So it drops the van der Waals
energy by 16.8 kilocalories
per mole, down to only 5.2.
That's how it does it, by moving
the two apart.
But it's at the expense of
stretching the bonds and
bending the bonds a little bit
to get those hydrogens apart
from one another.
So although it started with 109
degree bond angles at 1.52
angstroms, it changed like
this-- you can see how it
moved to get the hydrogens
apart, but there's
an expense to pay.
So even though we've gotten down
to only 5.2 kilocalories
per mole of van der Waals
strain, there's now an
increase to 4.8 kilocalories per
mole from
stretching and bending.
So the total strain in two
t-butyls
bonded together is 12.2--
that is 4.8 plus 5.2 plus 2.2 of
torsional
energy that's in there.
So that's where that number
comes from.
So that's the 12.2, and you can
do similar calculations to
get these other values.
Now notice something
interesting.
Those are strained in the
starting material.
But notice that the range of
that from 2.3 to 12.2 is 9.9.
So that's bigger, in fact, than
the whole range of this
difference attributed to
differences in the radicals.
That is, in the case of t-butyl
the starting material
for t-butyl-t-butyl is
strained enough to explain the
entire difference of why it's
easy to break
t-butyl-t-butyl--
not the radicals but the
starting material.
Now we can look at the case of
methyl, how much strain was
there in the starting material
when methyl is attached to
these various Rs.
And what you see is the same
thing, that the amount of
strain can explain the range of
difference in bond
association energies without say
the radicals are
different at all.
So for X equals alkyl, methyl,
ethyl, isopropyl, t-butyl, for
the X that's breaking away being
methyl, ethyl, isopropyl
or t-butyl, almost all of the
change is due to strain energy
in the starting material.
But not in the case of H-R,
because in the case of H-R
there's very little strain in
the starting material.
So there's something different
going on with
H-R. It's not typical.
So as far as I know, no one
really understands this, why
it is that way.
Now here we've done another plot
where we correct for the
R-X strain.
That is, subtract out that
strain in the starting
material and then see how
different they would be.
And you see there's hardly any
difference at all as you go
from methyl, ethyl, isopropyl,
t-butyl radicals.
So this is an alternative to the
hypothesis that radical
stabilization by substitution of
methyls for hydrogens--
more substituted radicals are
more stable, which I guarantee
you is what your books will say,
whatever book you're
looking at.
So the intrinsic C-C bond
strength corrected for strain
is practically insensitive to
the
substitution of the radicals.
But if you have C-H bonds they
are, indeed, weakened by
alkylation of the carbon, but no
one understands it.
On the other hand, if you have
chlorines--
chlorine or bromine, they go the
other way.
And again, nobody understands
it.
No one I know at least
understands this, but the
textbooks seem to be wrong.
So a word to the wise as you
look at
your different textbooks.
Now that's what we're going to
say about bond energies.
Now how can we predict
activation energies. When
you're not just breaking a bond,
but making a new bond as
you break the old bond?
What energy should that have?
Can we use the energies of
stable structures, ones that
we understand to the extent we--
it's clear that we don't really
understand things
perfectly--
can we infer the energies of
transition states so we're
able to predict reactivity?
For example, might exothermic
reactions be faster than
endothermic ones?
Now let me take this--
someplace I dropped my prop.
Is there a green thing over
there?
OK, you'll have to imagine my
green thing that I thought I
brought along.
I had a packing strip that comes
around big shipments.
So it's a piece of wire.
So imagine that there's a wire
between my two hands and I'm
holding it so that it goes like
this.
So it's like a reaction
coordinate.
What I'm showing you is an
endothermic reaction.
You start here, you go over a
barrier,
then you get to product.
Or if I lower the product, it
now looks like this.
You have that in your mind's
eye?
So I can go back and forth,
knowing the energy difference
between starting material and
product, I have some idea what
the activation energy might look
like.
Of course, this is really
nonsense.
Activation energy isn't a
packing strip like that, but
we can think of it that way.
And if that were so, then you
notice that an endothermic
reaction would have a high
transition state.
But an exothermic reaction would
have a
low transition state.
So we could go from a knowledge
of the starting
material and the products to
infer something about what the
activation energy was, as long
as we're looking at reactions
that are very, very similar to
one another.
So they would have the same kind
of strip.
So we're going to see if we can
use that to understand
something, to predict things,
about free-
radical make and break.
So we're not going to try to do
absolute
energies like this--
that's way too hard.
But we'll hope we can at least
do relative energies if we
look at analogous reactions.
So how can we predict activation
energy?
It's no easy task a priori,
especially when interaction
with the solvent is important.
But often you can say something
sensible about
relative values of the
activation energy or the free
energy of activation.
It's a question of compared to
what-- you want to compare two
things that are very close to
one another.
Now this is related to what's
called the Hammond Postulate.
George Hammond, who incidentally
was also a
student of Professor Bartlett
who's your chemical
grandfather as we talked about
last time--
in 1955 formulated something
that has become called the
Hammond Postulate.
What he actually said was, If
two states, for example, a
transition state and an unstable
intermediate, occur
consecutively during a reaction
process and have
nearly the same energy content,
there interconversion
will involve only a small
reorganization of molecular
structures.
I found my prop here.
So here's an exothermic
reaction.
Here's an endothermic reaction.
Now notice that the transition
state and the product are very
near one another in energy in
this case.
But they're also near one
another in structure, from
here to here.
Whereas if it were an exothermic
reaction, the
transition state is very
different from the product,
it's like the starting material,
and it's very near
in structure to the starting
material.
It's a little bit crummy, but I
think you got the idea.
So whether that's what you would
read into this
necessarily. I don't know.
But what is clear is that this
stimulated organic chemists to
begin thinking about transition
states and to try
to generalize plausibly about
reaction coordinates--
how you might infer from
starting material and product
energies, the kind of molecules
we know about, to
these transition states. When
one bond is being made and
another broken, for example,
which is very difficult to
reason about.
So here's another picture of the
same thing.
The more exothermic a reaction
the more similar the
transition state to the starting
material, both in
energy and in structure.
So here's the starting material,
here's the
transition state.
When it's very exothermic it's
close to the starting material
in energy, it's close to the
starting material in structure.
If it's not very exothermic,
then the transition state is
sort of halfway along, and
considerably above the
starting material in energy.
And if it's endothermic it's
near the product in energy and
in structure, so that the
reaction is then--
and the reaction is slow because
the transition state
is so much higher.
Now we can be fairly confident
of this, at least if we're
looking at very similar
reactions.
For example, the ones were
talking about.
If you have an X radical come up
and take H away from R, but
we vary X or we vary R to make
the reaction more or less
exothermic, then we might be
able to use this kind of
reasoning to get from one to
another.
Knowing one we can predict
Now there's likely a continuum
between starting material and
product with respect to factors
that influence stability.
For example, resonance
stabilization.
Remember the allyl radical and
the benzyl radical are
especially stable because they
have resonance stabilization,
the SOMO mixing with pi and
pi*.
So if we're talking relative to
just a regular old alkyl
group, methyl, so we got here
methane
goes to methyl radical.
So we make those, by definition,
the same, because
we're going to compare relative.
What happens if we have benzyl
with hydrogen on it and the
benzyl radical.
And we see that the benzyl
radical is more stable because
when you get here you have this
resonance stabilization.
And this idea that there's a
continuum is that the further
the transition state is along,
the more it will experience
that special stabilization.
So if the transition state, when
this bond is partly
broken because X is taking H
away, if it were a late
transition state like that, an
endothermic process, then it
should have a late--
if it were a late transition
state it should have pretty
much stabilization by resonance.
But if it's an exothermic
reaction and it's a very early
transition state, then it
shouldn't have much of this.
So the idea is that you're going
to have a steady
increase of this.
It might not be quite a straight
line, but at least
it's steadily going down.
So the rate of the slower
reaction should be more
sensitive to the overall
difference in free energy.
That is, if you have a very fast
reaction and you move
this up and down, change the
exothermicity, delta G, by
quite a bit, you hardly move
that at all.
But if it's an endothermic
reaction and you move this up
and down, this'll move up and
down almost as much.
So the reaction becomes less
sensitive to the delta G when
you have an exothermic reaction
because it happens so
near the starting material.
So this gives rise to what's
called the
Reactivity-Selectivity
Principle.
So here's an exothermic
reaction, here's an
endothermic reaction.
It could be pulling H off of
certain R by
chlorine or by bromine.
So it could look like this.
So this would be more reactive
and that
would be less reactive.
Higher activation energy.
But consider a similar pair of
reactions where you're pulling
the H away from a different R,
an R whose bond
is easier to break.
So the radical here is more
stable, at least compared to
the starting material-- it may,
in fact, be the starting
materials that are different as
we were talking about.
So you have a certain difference
here, it's the same
difference here-- you're going
from the same starting
material to the same radical,
it's just that in this case
you're using bromine to pull it
off, in this case you're
using chlorine.
So notice that in this stage
it's not selective because no
matter which of the compounds,
the blue RH or the red RH, no
matter which H you're pulling
off with the chlorine, they
have almost exactly the same
energy--
activation energy, the same
rate.
But here in the case of bromine
it's going to be more
selective because you're going
to have a bigger difference
because it's further along.
And I'll stop now and we'll pick
up here next time on this
Reactivity-Selectivity
Principle--
the idea that the less reactive
it is the more
selective it will be.
Thanks.